We know by instinct that humor is pretty important in relationships...
...but the reasons are often left a little vague.
It isn't that we crudely want entertainment;...
...there are enough comedians on TV.
We don't just want a laugh per se.
For two people to be able to tolerate one another over time,...
...we need to laugh,...
...in the nicest way, at our partner and at ourselves.
Spending time closely around someone inevitably exposes us...
...to constant departures from what we could call normality or balance.
Our partners will be a little crazy in many areas and we will be too, of course.
They might turn out to ring their mother five times a day,...
...clean the kitchen as if surgery was gonna be performed there,...
...always insist on inviting friends around,...
...or want to arrive at the airport six hours before a flight.
We need to say something, but doing so directly and in a serious voice...
...can be painfully counterproductive.
Too often, the partner just feels swiftly attacked and refuses the insight,...
...leading to stifled irritation and bitterness.
This is where humor comes in.
Humor is the most effective way of criticizing another person...
...without arousing their irritation or self-righteousness.
Their laughter isn't just fun.
It's a sign that they have acknowledged an attempt to reform them.